le patron de ferrero fait son mea culpa
suite au scandale sanitaire qui
éclabousse la marque je suis venu vous
dire que ce qui s'est passé n'est pas
acceptable on est désolé je suis désolé
en avril dernier ferrero rappel des
produits kinder en raison de cas de
salmonelloses bilan en france 81 enfants
malades 22 hospitalisé plusieurs
familles ont d'ores et déjà entamé une
action en justice
leur avocat dénonce une opération de
communication de la part du directeur de
la marque alors c'est vrai que ces
excuses arrive deux mois après le
scandale est-ce que c'est choquant oui
ou non alors là c'est joli
mot tabou oui c'est extrêmement choquant
d'autant plus qu'on avait découvert la
bactérie je crois un 15 décembre et que
il s'est à peine il s'appelle excusé il
a même pas en reconnu la culpabilité il
s'est juste excusé et ce qu'ils ont
proposé jeudi aux familles des victimes
et que tellement dérisoire et je suis
très content que de farine à royan porté
plainte contre la société ferrero et
j'espère bien qu'ils vont payer cher non
alors blondel ça je vous dis tout de
suite la réponse est non non la réponse
est non à bâle je vous le dis en droit
français mais on en n'est pas en
amérique donc ici le riz de choix que le
risque maximum ils vont trouver deux nos
responsables de cette liste comprend à
les 12 mois de prison avec sursis
peut-être et il y aura dix mille euros
damende c'était un site grand maximum
c'était un site en belgique le site
d'arlon oui alors vous dites non non
mais c'est une communication qui
arrivent tard certes mais au moins elle
est claire elle explicative voilà l
explicative il reconnaît ses torts il
s'est excusé il prend le temps des
crises qu'il a échangé avec les lecteurs
du parisien donc franchement à part le
faire un peu plus tôt jean parce qu'il
aurait pu faire d'autres et surtout il a
rassuré les consommateurs qui n'auraient
pas des systèmes avec les autres marques
produits dans cette usine et les autres
produits donc je vois pas ce qui me
faire d'autre à part communiqué mais les
excuses à son maladroite elles sont très
maladroit parce que l'on aime il ya
quand même des des enfers à l'hôpital
etc c à b excusez-nous c'est quand même
très simple et très très faible il y
aurait peut-être même dû dire excusez
moi je démissionne ou quelque chose de
fort parce que là c'est vous avez été
malade on est désolé
on va porter même pour le groupe ferrero
quand même c'est 40 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires
mille tonnes de produits qui ont été que
qui ont été balancés à la poubelle il ya
des employés qui arrive de perdre leur
travail évidemment il ya le scandale
sanitaire mais aussi une entreprise qui
fait mis beaucoup de gens mais non mais
ça va continuer le millier de personnes
qu encore une chance et aussi la
froideur des dirigeants qui aussi tu
leur entreprise avec cette communication
si pitoyable c'est à dire que s'il avait
réagi tout de suite en communiquant ce
manière publique et 2 en allant à la
rencontre des familles puisque je me
rappelle ici qu'on avait reçu une maman
qui nous avait expliqué la terrible
maladie de sa fille et qu'elle nous
avait expliqué que personne ne l'avait
contacté ni pour s'excuser ni pour lui
dire mais renie rien à un moment tu déjà
tu manques de respect envers les
consommateurs tutu la marque et tu suis
les salariés qu'ils assurent alors donc
c'est triple peine pour la marque je
vous rassure findus tout le monde a
oublié enfin venu s'il y avait moi et
des amis du cheval dans les dents de
lait lazaoui donc c'est pareil c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça à mon avis que tu me
tony laisse courir pour qu'on n'oublie
d'affaires